I don't know what you think but I would
think that anybody who earned his living
by writing or directing would like to
give Joe mankiewicz a double Mickey but
you just can't trust anybody anymore
instead for two years in a row they went
and gave him a double Oscar and even
more remarkable tribute to Joe is that
because of him children who couldn't
normally spell
antidisestablishmentarianism now have no
trouble at all with mankiewicz
now we give him his chance at the
microphone to present the directors
award mr. Joseph L mankiewicz
this year's nominees for best
achievement in directing ah and in all
cases these men directed to picture the
African Queen horizon enterprises
incorporated United Artists John Huston
an American in Paris metro-goldwyn-mayer
Vincente Minnelli detective story
paramount William Waller a Place in the
Sun paramount George Stevens and a
streetcar named desire Charles K Feldman
Group productions Warner Brothers Elia
Kazan and the winner the winner is
George Stevens for the nominated 1943 -
the more the merrier this time
making his proceed
the center of the stage being warmly in
rasam be congratulated by Joe mankiewicz
and now Stephens speaks excluding mr.
Hornbeck and miss head and mr. Brown and
mr. Wilson and mr. Waxman and mr. melih
I'd like to say thank you to all of
those other talented people that brought
us here tonight thank you